des vieilles photos d'anciens manuels
scolaires des médailles de mérite pour
les bons élèves et des tonnes de
documents qui ont échappé aux affres du
temps et aux dégâts d'eau cash subi le
siège social de la commission scolaire
de montréal en 1951 il est venu visiter
les enfants depuis 20 ans alain
beauchamp fouilles l'histoire des écoles
de montréal
maynooth à 46 c était les premiers
procès-verbaux des comme ça on les
hollandais jusqu'à aujourd'hui
on y trouve le salaire annuel des
enseignants en 1850 chats les chiens
qu'un clip les lits failli gagner -
chaque rigaux au début du 20e siècle
les élèves ont deux professeurs de
dessin qui vont marquer le monde des
arts
c'est pas rien jusqu'à ce que le
gouvernement péquiste transforme les
commissions scolaires confessionnelles
en entités linguistiques
on parle de la commission des écoles
catholiques de montréal
la ccm ont projeté sur un écran pour le
meur ils sont complètement dépassés mais
ces tableaux sont les premiers supports
visuels des enseignants c'est curieux la
fin des années 20 y avait pas vraiment
de matériel pédagogique vient des
historiens savent qu'ils vont trouver
des trésors ici comme des photos
rappelant les efforts pour maintenir les
élèves en bonne santé
les souvenirs sportifs de l'école le
plateau en 1942 ont été numérisés
le service des archives a beaucoup à
faire avant le déménagement du siège
social de la csdm qui s'amorcera dès
on continue la numérisation d'une foule
de documents y compris les bulletins des
anciens élèves de la csdm les bulletins
sa big mama 15 t on les numérisant les
concerts sur de longues périodes allant
jusqu'à 60 20 on
non le devoir à la csdm de conserver les
bulletins et relevé note
est ce donc qui souhaitent obtenir leurs
bulletins pour telle ou telle année dans
telle ou telle école de la bm ou de la
cec m
ils peuvent l'obtenir moyens dans une
dizaine de dollars et ça marche
est ce que vous vous souvenez si vous
étiez un bon élève venu coiffer sa mère
oui un des bons élèves c'est relatif
salué par les amis à l'école notre-dame
de grâce de la cia à l'époque louis
aliot non non je pense qu'au bout par un
extrait vous croyez être contente oui
croyez mais j'espère bien en tout cas
mais ça me rappelle de bons souvenirs je
salue donc mes profs de l'époque qu'est
l'histoire mais merci je peux le
conserver à la wii qui vous pouvez même
le montrèrent vous fait vous croyez oui
oui c'est assez ça dépend des matières
je crois merci beaucoup
elle et ses nuits